لقد تعبوا من الإرهاق ،
وبالنسبة للعديد من الأشخاص الموجودين هنا في
محطة القطار هذه ، ليس لديهم أي فكرة عن المكان
الذي سينامون فيه الليلة أو
خلال الليلتين التاليتين سنكون في
محطة القطار في شيا ميشيل حوالي
30 دقيقة أو  لذلك داخل
الحدود وصل قطار من كيث للتو إلى
هنا ويحاول الناس معرفة
إلى أين يذهبون من هنا بعض الناس
يرفعون لافتات تعرض رحلات إلى
أجزاء مختلفة من بولندا ، وهناك أيضًا
الكثير من المتطوعين هنا يوزعون الطعام
يحاولون أيضًا ربطهم
بأماكن للبقاء في بعض الأحيان ، ربما تكون
صالة ألعاب رياضية مدرسية قد
يقيمون فيها
في حالات أخرى ، فإن العائلات هي التي
عرضت بالفعل استقبال النساء
والأطفال وكذلك الآن الحكومة الأوكرانية
ليست كذلك  السماح للرجال الذين تتراوح
أعمارهم بين 18 و 60 عامًا بالخروج من البلاد على الرغم من أننا التقينا
ببعضهم هنا ، فقد تحدثنا إلى
رجل في الأربعينيات من عمره في وقت سابق اليوم والذي
وصف الاضطرار إلى إقناع حرس الحدود
بمحاولة السماح لهم بالترحيب  الذي
تمكن من القيام به
، يصف أيضًا الفوضى
الناتجة عن ركوب هذا القطار وتدافع
الأشخاص الذين ليس لديهم تذاكر ولكنهم يائسون
للخروج من البلاد معظم الناس
لم يكن لديهم التذاكر لذلك
اقتحموا القطار فقط أعني  كان الأمر
أشبه بالتدافع الذي
كان الناس يشبهون محاولة الدخول إليه
بغض النظر عما لم يكن أحد يتحقق من
التذاكر بالفعل لأنني أعني أنه من الواضح أن معظم
الناس لم يكن لديهم أي تذاكر
، فقد كانت الفوضى كانت الفوضى كانت هناك
فوضى كان الكثير من الناس  مثل
التجوال
ولكنني أعني أن الناس
يركضون للفرار للنجاة بحياتهم ، لذلك
لا ألومهم
، وجدنا أيضًا رجالًا أوكرانيين
يعيشون هنا في بولندا ينتظرون في
محطة القطار هذه حتى يصل أحباؤهم
غير قادرين على العودة بأنفسهم.  تحدث إلى
شخص في وقت سابق اليوم كان ينتظر
وصول عائلته وسألته
عما إذا كان على استعداد للعودة إلى
أوكرانيا وقال نعم
إذا ساء الوضع ليس إذا
تحسن الوضع ولكن إذا ساء ، قال  نعم هو على
استعداد للانضمام إلى الجيش ومستعد
للقتال والموت من أجل بلاده إذا كان
الأمر يتعلق بذلك سكوت مكلين CNN في شيا
ميشيل بولندا